Я розуміла, що захворію… рано чи пізно ти неодмінно захворієш.
Оце слово - "виявлено". І така образа. Я так плакала...
Я так старалася, все організовувала - це моє дітище.
Мене ніколи не бачили без маски.
Мене звати Кравчук Олена Вікторівна. Я заступник головного лікаря
з медичної частини КНП "Любарська центральна районна лікарня".
У нас у певний період хворіли багато лікарів, медсестер, санітарок.
Більша частина медперсоналу перехворіла.
Я також інфікувалася.
Після мене захворіла завідувачка інфекційним відділенням.
Ми з нею помінялися, тобто я надавала допомогу замість неї -
тут, в інфекційному відділенні, як звичайний лікар.
Я працювала безпосередньо з хворими на "ковід". Працювала виснажливо, оскільки я не була готова.
Я сама за фахом невропатолог. Але дуже багато персоналу захворіло.
Тоді у нас ще величезний спалах був у Любарі - приходило 58 людей за добу.
Людей було дуже багато і було дуже багато важких.
Я навчилася працювати на апараті ШВЛ в режимі СІПАП.
В мене вибору не було.
Мій чоловік - анестезіолог.
У мене людина помирає, і я не знаю, що робити.
Я перед тим почитала, вивчила цей апарат.
Я прийшла, спробувала. Чоловік по гучному зв'язку каже: "Так і так, так і так".
Я кажу: "Я підключила - росте, так, все!"
Радість була. Така радість.
Я не одну людину підключала, не одну знімала.
Ми працюємо одне за одного. Як немає санітарки, я можу так само погодувати пацієнта,
подати йому щось - зробити те, що робить санітарка.
Зараз в реанімації лежить друг мого батька.
Ти до нього ставишся, як до батька.
Тобто я завжди думаю, що це можуть бути мої батьки.
Я розумію, що в мене є батьки, в мене є друзі, знайомі, куми, сусіди.
Тобто це невелике містечко, щоб, як у місті, бути більш холоднокровною.
Мій чоловік працює в обласній лікарні. Він анестезіолог в обласній Житомирській лікарні.
Він проживає там, я проживаю тут. Він приїжджає сюди.
Ми мали переїхати в Житомир, ми там купили житло.
Ми мали забирати дітей, але "ковід" розставив все на свої місця.
Зараз я цих людей покинути не можу.
Я сама з Любара, я любарська, я повинна своїх людей підтримати і я їх не покину.
У мене є діти, які мені готують їсти і пишуть записку: "Мамо, тільки підігрій".
Тобто о першій ночі я приходжу, а в мене вже приготовлено моїми дітьми.
Мої батьки ніколи не лягають спати, поки я не прийду додому, вони на мене чекають.
І тут я інфікувалася. Страшно, звичайно, страшно. Дуже страшно.
Страшно тим, що ти бачила, як це може закінчитись.
Я перехворіла легко, я вважаю. Єдине, що у мене були дуже сильні болі
- болі в спині, дуже сильна ломота, і тільки на п'ятий день я втратила нюх і смак.
Я протирала підлогу, мама зайшла і каже: "Боже, доцю, ти ж потравиш дітей!"
Я кажу: "Що таке?" А вона каже: "Скільки ти тієї хлорки налила?"
Я кажу: "Мамо, я нічого не відчуваю".
Це перший раз, коли я зрозуміла, що не відчуваю запаху.
Але нічого - з Божою допомогою, пневмонії в мене не було, і я на 14-й день вийшла на роботу.
Ти бачила людей, які навіть не помітили, що вони хворіють, а мали позитивний ПЛР,
і бачила людей, які не мали ПЛР позитивного, але помирали.
Основна причина - це те, що вони поступають вже із запізненням.
ПЛР вже негативний, але масивні пневмонії.
Тобто оце ті скептики, які не вірять.
Деякі люди кажуть: "Ой, чого я піду, в мене грошей немає".
Це дуже частий аргумент - "в мене немає грошей".
Інші кажуть: "А я ніколи в лікарні не був", а треті:
"Я не вірю в це - це звичайний грип, звичайна ГРВІ".
Ні, це не звичайна ГРВІ.
Найгірше попереду. Однозначно - найгірше попереду.
Ніхто не скасовував грип.
Ми мали величезні спалахи грипу в період листопад-грудень.
Тобто однозначно це буде трохи плутанина.
Але є різниця - ми знаємо, як грип лікувати,
а "ковід" ми не знаємо, як лікувати.
Я вважаю, що обов’язково потрібно провакцинуватися від грипу.
Це, за моїм власним досвідом, дає результати.
Я б хотіла, щоб Ви запитали мене: "Як Ви вважаєте, що зараз найцінніше?"
Для когось - нафта, для когось - золото.
Запитайте моїх пацієнтів, що найдорожче. Найдорожче зараз - кисень.
Як людина тягнеться рукою - наскільки видно залежність від нього!
І ти бачиш, що людина живе, вона оживає.
Ти накладаєш їм маску, і вони очима тільки шукають, щоб побачити свою сатурацію.
Буває так, що ти поставиш на менше - подивитися, яка динаміка.
Вони тягнуть руку, щоб зробити більше - самостійно.
Я кажу: "Вам не можна, вам вже треба відвикати, ми вас відлучаємо".
Люди дуже лякаються.
Нам виділяє держава кошти на кисень, і ми закуповуємо за ці кошти кисень.
Незручність - у доставці.
Це віддалений район, по-друге, в нас немає достатньо машин,
та й всі машини вже мають поважний вік.
Тобто наша машина - "Газель"  - бере дев'ять балонів,
а мені треба дев'ять балонів на шість годин.
"Газель" приїжджає, привозить мені кисень, забирає порожні балони, їде в Житомир, заправляє.
Я вважаю, треба по всій країні - ця ж проблема не тільки у нас,
про це говорить вся країна - організувати мережу доставок.
Неодноразово я, засинаючи, прокручувала такий сценарій:
що буде, якщо закінчиться кисень?
Навіть можу сказати так: здається, це все-таки настане.
З такою швидкістю - настане.
Фахівці повинні були вже це продумати.
Так, як в Китаї було - інші заводи переобладнати і подумати, як ми забезпечимо потребу в кисні.
Це буде - і ми не встигнемо.
І вийти просто зачинити двері за пацієнтом, просто сказати, що кисню немає?
Якщо не буде кисню, відсоток смертей зросте -
їх буде в два, в три, в чотири рази більше.
Я дуже весела людина, а стала такою жорсткою.
І думаю, а далі що буде?
У мене є вислів - це вислів мого чоловіка, який завжди каже:
"Альона, якщо ти здашся, легше тобі від цього не стане".
І я вважаю, що це правильно.
Ну, здамся я - що в моєму житті зміниться?
Крім того, що я стану невдахою? І покинула лікарню та хворих?
Я вважаю, що треба працювати…